[Music]
today's show we talk about heavy
heavy topics we talk with a veteran
who's emotionally abusive and who wants
to change
we talk with a young man who is trapped
in some family situations
we talked with a young woman who
experienced unimaginable family trauma
and she doesn't know what to do next
stay tuned
hey what's up this is john with the dr
john deloney's show
i don't know why i just growled my name
i i'm trying to
still live out my punk rock singer
dreams that i'm
clearly didn't happen now i work
on a on a show there's no punk rock
there's some punk rockiness to this is
there no there's not that's embarrassing
your shirt's pretty punk rock today
disagree it's got bones on it that looks
tough and scary
kind of not really so hey i'm glad
you're here
so i just i gotta just be
transparent i the last
like three or four nights man i have
just done
these long fasts i've been fasting for
several days with the
with a with a meal sprinkled in here and
there it's a whole
whole long thing but last night i
finished my final
20 hour i think it was 22 hour fast
and we have some people over and my wife
had
these homemade cookies so i finished
this fast
have this awesome she made this great
like beef and venison
taco salad and then i had 1750 cookies
and they're so good and then i slept
like garbage
and then after sleeping like garbage i
got up and today's deadlift day and you
won't be that guy
and make any references to any sort of
leg day at all because you sound like an
idiot
but it was that day and i just sat in
the gym this morning
and just it was embarrassing man but
then i got through it
you got to power through on those days
hey i paid the i
had to pay the piper on those that many
cookies man
and then you got to be upset with
yourself and then give yourself some
grace and move on
so you had to do some extra deadlifts
today that i am struggling
struggling but luckily we've got kelly
o'kelly's leaving so we had kelly
and uh james is here he looks great just
just a bundle of energy this morning and
zach always the
joyful zach is here and we're gonna
power through we're gonna get it today
we got a couple of cool shows coming up
we have a father's day show coming up
we've got
some good stuff coming man so if you
want to be on the show give me a call at
1-844-693-3291-2184-693-3291
here's the meta lesson there is a
connection between the garbage you put
in your body and how bad you sleep and
then how bad you sleep has a direct
impact on whether you want to exercise
and be a present parent or human in the
morning
and that has a direct impact on
how good you're going to perform at work
so what's the lesson here eat take care
of your body
take care of your body and if you do get
off the wagon don't ever fall off the
wagon just
climb park it climb off of it roll
around in the mud let it run over you a
few times if that's what you need to do
which is what i did and then you got to
pay the price man you got to get in
there
and earn it back in the gym and then
you've got to
come to work perform do well be kind and
then go from there 1-844-693-3291
or go to johnology.com
show be on this to be on the show goes
to kelly she makes the decisions because
we all
live in kelly's world all right let's go
straight to the phones
i'll say straight to the phones i've
been talking for like 30 minutes now
let's now finally
after i'm rambling about my failures
last night go
to richie in raleigh north carolina
what's up brother richie how are we
doing man
hey rich sir uh dr deloney good morning
i'm really nervous sorry about that hey
i am too man i i'm still
i when's the last time you crushed
a sleeve of cookies man ah
i think it's been a few months at least
see talking to people with self-control
is
it's good for me hey so what's up
brother thanks for calling man how can i
help dude
oh thank you dr deloney first of all
thank you so much for taking my call i
really do appreciate it sir
um my name's richie i live here in
raleigh um i'm a marine corps veteran
i'm originally from a small town up in
ohio and i've been out of the marine
corps for a few years now
um i i am or i was
um an emotionally abusive
uh boyfriend or ex-boyfriend with my ex
a few years ago um and i'm
i i've kind of started dating this one
new girl
again i've been out of the dating scene
for a few years and i'm
honestly i'm terrified i'm not really
sure what to expect
my relationship with my parents is not
very good at all
um i i started going to church but
that's
i mean that's hit or miss that's a whole
other
conversation right yeah honestly um
but i'm i'm terrified i don't want to
repeat this
i've been going to therapy for a little
over a year now okay
and um so what what yeah what does well
number one dude
just you've done some brave things in
your day and this is probably
up there at the top um i've run around
with guys i've been a part of
swat trainings and worked in the
military i've seen some stuff and heard
some even wilder stories
and there's always components of bravery
but as far as i'm concerned there are a
few
braver things than saying
i'm an emotionally abusive guy and i
don't i i want to be different than that
so on behalf of
men everywhere and more importantly
behalf on behalf of the
wives and kids that are subject to that
thank you for being a brave guy
and trying to turn and stare this thing
down appreciate that man um
doesn't excuse you being an idiot right
but you're a brave guy
right so walk me back a couple things um
how long are you in the in the
in the marine corps man i just did four
years
four years what was your exit rank yeah
i got out as a sergeant okay outstanding
man so did you see combat did you go
overseas what was your roles i went
overseas twice i was motor t
um i was never personally in combat
however i was in
the uh the area if that makes any sense
at all
yeah dude of course hey everybody's on
the team man
everybody's on the team i know there
gets to be a
oh yeah well i will i man you went
overseas and you and you
served your country brother so i
appreciate that so tell me about
what a emotional abusive means what does
that mean to you
what'd you do oh man i i was pulling
manipulative
i lied um oh
for god's sake um it was
i i i became a christian uh if that
matters at all after
we uh after i joined the military and i
was like
teetering the fence of uh hey we
shouldn't be having sex but hey let's go
have sex
you know and and so she was torn because
she was
she i think she believed in god at the
time i'm not even sure anymore
um this is a few years ago now hey
you're cycling out on me though hold on
you're you're doing some excellent
evasive maneuvers
how are you emotionally abusive
oh man um
i made it all about myself i was selfish
i didn't care what she wanted to do i
didn't i wanted
i wanted to please myself in the
relationship
i wanted to if i wanted to go out and
party i was going to go out and party
and leave her behind
um i i it was i
and if i wanted to go see other girls at
the same time i was going to go do that
too
gotcha um so that that makes it makes
that makes it sound more like you're
just a jerk
like just a scummy boyfriend how are you
abusive
did you yell at her do you swear did you
did you put your hands on her how are
you
um abusive
oh like she cried all the time all the
time in the relationship so
and i and this is i i've given my myself
uh like a self-diagnosis if that matters
at all dr daloni um but i've just
i i figured that this is all as i
reflect it must have been all emotional
abuse
not physical never physical but it was
always manipulation
she was crying all the time even towards
the end of the relationship i was like
listen
i am so unhappy and you are so unhappy
she wanted to stick through the
relationship
and i was like this is bonkers so where
did you where did you pick that up
where did you learn to talk to
somebody in that way where did you learn
that you're
oh man your path was the most important
path
and someone that you love who cares man
um friends family whatever um
virtue uh values screw all that i'm
plowing through with whatever i want to
do
[Applause]
oh man it it
uh it really
sorry um no it's all good brother
somebody somebody taught you that
where'd you pick that up was it mom or
was it dad was it the
core where did you pick it up it was my
father it was my father
it our relationship basically
it became an exact mirror image of my
parents marriage
uh okay so this is how men treat women
right
yeah literally that was what i knew and
i'm i'm the only guy it was me my dad
and i've got
four sisters so you know it was
i oh man it was awful so
yeah you break up with this with this
woman and
you take some time off why'd you take
some time off
i i felt like i was being suffocated
you were being suffocated yeah
how ironic right it's like it's like you
got both hands around somebody's neck
and you're choking them to death and you
stop choking because
man my hands are sore right like you're
the yeah
you're on the bottom end of this deal so
then you meet somebody and you fall back
in love
and you've already done something stupid
what have you done so far well
i mean i i took some time off from
dating and i've been going to therapy
and now very recently i've started
dating again
yeah but so you've
violated what you had had you had some
ideas about some pictures about what
this thing was going to look like you've
already screwed those up what have you
already done
oh we're already sleeping together okay
like
if that's what you're getting there no
no no i'm i'm getting it
have you already lied to her have you
already pressured her to do something
she wasn't comfortable with have you
already gone out and seen somebody else
when you
this woman thinks y'all are exclusive
have you already yelled at her have you
already
like swore at her flexed on her a little
bit
you know it's it's the online dating
apps is what it is
i'm chatting up with other with other
women at the same time okay
and so what made you say enough
i i want to change man i want to be
different i want to i want to do this
as right as i possibly can i want to
i i'm so this is what i said recently to
my therapist i said i'm so
sick of just putting on a front and
playing pretend
i'm exhausted it's like i'm exhausted
from it
i hope that makes sense but i'm just
like yeah totally i
i i want to be a new
person i want to be a different person i
want
playing the games is
i don't know like i'm turning 30 soon
you know like i can't keep doing this
man
yeah like dude i i want something
different i want this change i want this
anything and everything i'm i don't want
to keep repeating my parents marriage
that ended years ago but it's the only
picture of marriage you got so
paint me a picture of what you want
like what do you want this to look like
oh man um a white picket fence golden
retriever and 10 million dollars in the
bank account
i don't know um i
i i just want us to be happy together i
know but listen
listen like content when you run from
something
without a direction of where you're
gonna head you don't get anywhere
you just keep replaying the same tape
over and over
and so where yeah do you want to be a
guy who values
his girlfriend who values his wife
that she feels safe around that he can
keep his mouth shut and not
ever ever swear at her
ever yell because yelling is the sign of
a somebody who's lost all control
yelling is what children do
do you want to be a guy who is
trustworthy
and doesn't cheat on
the person that they love i mean is that
what you're looking for
absolutely yeah but you can't say that
why can't you say that
it sounds like a fantasy to me why it
sounds like something it
it's like a hollywood
it's like a hollywood movie fairy tale
lie
um i i see some of these marriages i see
some of these people and they look so
happy together and it's
where's the honesty where's the struggle
where's the hay
or i i don't know maybe it's because all
my military buddies all of them are now
divorced
they're all under second or third or
fourth marriages like my
when i look at close friends of mine
when i look at my immediate family the
track record is
is a big fat zero and and
i that's that's what i that's what i see
that's what i i know that's what i
uh that that's the the groups of people
i surround myself with
there you go right there right there
okay that's it
so i'll tell you can you have a great
marriage absolutely
does great marriage mean there's never
conflict no anyone who tells you that is
lying to you
marriage is hard real hard
and it's messy and people hurt each
other and they say i'm sorry
and then they don't talk for a day then
they get back together
that's the nature of marriage it's hard
and it's always worth it if you got two
people invested in making the other
person's life as good as possible
and when you look at what you want in
your life and you haven't done that
you know what you don't want you you
know the hollowness of the life you're
in right now
the hard work is figuring out what it is
you do want and here's why that's hard
to do because once you nail it down
then you know there's a gap between an
unmet mission
and how you're choosing to live
and that's the difference up between you
now you're able to just roll your eyes
and say it's just the way it always is
and this always happens this way
once you say i want this now you know
you got to go get it
and choosing not to go get it is a
choice and that falls on you
and then you can't blame your old man
you can't blame your buddies you can't
blame the system you can't blame people
lying to you blah blah blah
you've got to do the hard work of saying
this is what i want and then you gotta
go make that happen
it's the same as if you want to lift
weights it's the same if you want to
become a better shot
it's the same if you want to move up to
sergeant you got to do these things to
get there
and then when you look around at the
people around you
if you know wood doesn't sharpen iron
so you got to get a better group of
people to hang out with and i know a
bunch of veterans with
impeccable marriages that are hard and
messy
and full of forgiveness and full of
starting over almost on a weekly basis
but i don't buy that because you're in
the military because you're
hard because you've seen stuff that you
can't have a good marriage that's not
true
it's not and so that means
it the question is going to come down to
how bad do you want this
how bad do you want to be able to sleep
all night
without medication how bad you want to
be able to get up in the morning how bad
do you want somebody that's going to be
ride or die with you and you her how bad
do you want kids
that are going to love you and respect
you and not be running around when
they're 30 trying to figure out how to
love somebody
how bad you want that and then it's
relatively simple moving forward and
it it makes me sound callous right
because it's um
how do you lose weight diet and exercise
man it's hard it's simple but it's hard
right yeah this is very similar
starting today you will
never ever lie to a girlfriend again
period ever
you will never yell or swear or be
disrespectful again
you may have to walk out the front door
and take a walk around down the
neighborhood
you may have to cut somebody off on the
phone and say hey i need to hang up
and i will call you back in five minutes
and then hang up the phone
you got to do what you have to do but
you have to decide
starting today i will never do this
again
and when you fail which you will you'll
catch yourself in the middle of a lie
and you'll stop and say hold on hold on
i did go see somebody last night and i'm
sorry
i did or on your way to go see somebody
you will stop and you'll text that
person say i'm not coming i'm actually
in a committed relationship he'll turn
on and go home
or in the middle of yelling or in the
middle of trying to talk somebody into
sleeping with you again when she doesn't
want to
you'll stop and say hey i actually value
your values you'll stop
here's what i want you to do i want you
to get a a small picture of your old man
and every time you yell or cheat or
lie i want you to pull that picture up
and i want you to look at it
and i want you to say hey man i value
you more than her
every time
because that's what you're choosing at
this point you're choosing to to
walk a path that your old man cut for
you in the woods he didn't do a very
good job
and i don't want to be in the business
of running down people's dads but he
didn't do a good job
it's way harder to carve a new path and
so i want you to carry that with you for
a while
it's just it's just choosing you know
what dad i'm gonna follow you man
i value you more than her i value you
more than
my future kids i'm gonna have
and at some point you're gonna have to
forgive yourself for the
jerk that you were and you haven't done
yet that yet either
you carry that around with you a lot
yeah every day and so it's when you have
you may have heard me talk about this
there's you should feel guilty
when you swear at your girlfriend you
should because that's
garbage it's trash it's what children do
you should feel guilty when you yell at
somebody should feel guilty when you lie
to him
there's a difference between losing your
cool
not having the tools in your tool kit
and
saying i lied to you versus i'm a liar
right that's when you decide to put that
brick of guilt in your backpack and
carry it around with you forever
and that's what you've done i'm a liar
i'm a cheater
i'm a scumbag i'm just like my old man i
always will be this is the way this is
gonna be forever
and the more you carry that around all
that baggage comes with you
and of course your knees always hurt and
your back always hurts and you don't
want to
have to learn any new things you're
carrying all this crap around you got to
set that down man
okay you gotta set it down let's go
carrying him
i need you in my community a whole
well guy i need you going to the gym
i need you still training in some sort
of
you know kickboxing you just i need you
still taking care of yourself
i need you still having male friends in
your life good ones that will hold you
accountable
and you're still trying to get better
i'm proud of you for going to counseling
dude that's hard to do
but it sounds like you i know folks who
go to counseling for a year and they
just become complaint sessions
and the counselor is happy to take your
money
and you need to get with somebody that
will call your bluff and hold you
accountable
okay but here's the thing brother i am
i'm i am just blown away by your bravery
to even have this conversation and i
have one
thousand percent confidence in you
because i've seen it before
tell me about this girl you're dating
um we uh we met on an online
dating app um and we just hit it off
really well
okay um i
i think we are very emotionally
based um
i mean which emotions i guess they're
not bad but it's intimidating
um i try to be as logical as i can but
anyway
um she's a really nice girl she's a
nurse full-time so she works a lot
i don't know we love to laugh we love to
spend time together
we're very intimate a lot i will say
she has experienced some trauma in her
life as well
um not from her parents but from uh
from an ex-boyfriend i don't know too
many details about that i didn't ask i
didn't want to press send i wasn't sure
if it was
sure the right place or time to ask her
about that
those those conversations will come in
due time the more you prove that you're
trustworthy
and that you're safe and one of the sad
facts about people who are
traumatized and relationships full of
trauma is
the body craves homeostasis man it knows
that track and it will go find that
track again
and so it doesn't surprise me that
somebody who's experienced trauma finds
another guy who's
skilled in trauma right yeah
and so i i like like you i like emotions
but they are directional they're not um
they don't often tell me the truth right
they let me know i'm not okay they're
alarm systems but they don't tell me the
truth
so when you get emotional i want you to
write that stuff down man get that crap
out of your head and onto a piece of
paper
and then go through it and say is this
true or is this not true
am i really angry with her am i or am i
just scared i'm going to screw this up
and then when you can look at somebody
that you care about and say hey i'm
scared i'm going to screw this up
because i've screwed this up every time
in the past
and thank you for letting me say these
words out loud and it's embarrassing for
me because i'm a hardcore
marine corps vet but i'm learning i'm
practicing i'm trying
i don't know how to love you other than
just a hug and
at some point y'all become when you have
a nurse who's dealing with trauma all
day and you're
a guy who has dealt in trauma your whole
life and you're still on fight or flight
still run and run
there becomes this man you all become a
um a bandage for one another right until
you both bleed through the bandage and
then you gotta rip it off and go find
somebody else find a new bandage and you
become somebody else's new bandage
i want you guys to heal from the inside
out
man you deserve that man you deserve
that richie i hate what was happening
what happened he was a kid i hate that
model you got
and i hate that you've hurt people but
man i'm proud of you for saying no more
decide decide i will never yell again
i will never lie again i will always be
on time
and as you lean into those truths i will
never yell by the way anybody out there
who yells you're a child
a child who gets so mad i have to raise
my voice that means you've completely
lost control of yourself
and anybody you're trying to lead
yelling instantly turns people into
fight or flight
all they are thinking about at that
point is how do i get out of this
situation
towards safety quit learning
quit trying to connect
but i'm going to say no more i'm gonna
say no more and i think you can richie
if you decide so i want you to go to
your counselor and say
i'm making some declarations and i need
some accountability and i want to work
on accountability with you and if your
counselor says well how does it make you
feel just get up and walk out and go
find somebody else
you're better than that you need
somebody better than that but i'm proud
of you brother
i'm proud of you now it's time to go do
the hard work and make change
that starts with deciding where you want
to go where you want to go
hey what's up i want to take a quick
break to talk about the most important
question i'm asked almost every day
how do i find a counselor if you can't
find a counselor in your area
or you can't afford one i've got a
solution
for you i've partnered with a better
help for customized
online therapy video chat text chat
phone counseling it's a licensed
therapist whenever and wherever
you need them go to betterhelp.com
deloney for 10 off your first month it's
cheaper and it's available
all the time this is for you your family
and for everyone else that's coming your
way
take care of your mental health go to
deloney
betterhelp.com
all right let's go out to brandon in
meridian
brandon what's up my man hi dr john
thanks for taking my call you got it
brother how can i help
well i've got three major stresses going
on in my life
right now and they're all kind of
intertwined and
and they're so jumbled up that i get
myself wrapped around in circles and i
can't
i just shut down and i can't figure out
a way to start attacking these
well thanks for calling man let's
untangle them what you got okay
i've got well the first probably most
major there
um is my wife and i've been trying to
have a baby for
three and a half years now and so far
unable to get pregnant
i've got we're saving to buy a house and
this place that we love
and the goal line keeps moving and it
feels like we're never going to get to
the point where
we're going to be able to buy a house
here
i've got a job working for my dad and
he's getting ready to
he wants to exit the business and turn
it over to me and i'm not sure i want to
do that and then also even if i don't do
that
where do i go from here
[Music]
so it's all it's a lot right now and
it's all pretty heavy
and uh and and i'm stuck
well man i appreciate your trust and
give me a call dude that means a lot
um so when here's just a simple
guidelines when i'm in a situation like
you're in
which is both existential and practical
right existential being who am i going
to be am i going to be a dad
am i going to and i've been in that same
that same seat man and then you start
having conversations about adoption and
what does that look like
and then you or your wife feel guilty
and that leads to this whole
weird dance it's just a mess right um
yeah so you've got that number one
and that leads to i had a picture of
what my life was gonna be which is i'm
gonna take over dad's business in this
little community that we like we're
gonna have
18 little kids running around and then
suddenly that
that picture gets untethered right it
just the string pulls and it starts to
come apart
and then you want to buy a house yeah
and you're right man
we looked for nine months and we still
bought a
kind of a hidden in the woods
fixer-upper-ish kind of you know what i
mean like
yeah yeah because the housing market's
bananas
so now am i going to be a dad i'm not
going to be a homeowner and then tell me
about your
your dad's business what's the business
um it's a construction business just a
small company
and kind of a niche market but we're
doing really well so do you want out
i don't know no you do
well i mean in my heart i do but uh but
what do you want to do it's beer based
or
what do you want to do
if your dad said hey i just sold the
business to my neighbor for a million
dollars
here's half of it go do what you want he
gave you half a million dollars and said
go get him what would you go do
um
dude you work construction you've been
daydreaming about this for months
if not years what would you go do
oh man i don't know something outdoors i
guess um
something i don't know
it what i feel like i need is is
something that has a little bit more
meaning
um something that uh i feel like i'm
really
making an effect on people okay that's
positive and
so meaning is going to be meaning is
going to be
something you create it's not gonna be
an external source
i know guys that have a porta potty
company that have great meaning
like they find value in what they do and
know guys who pour concrete that find it
like they they understand that without
them people don't get from point a to
point b
and some yeah dude they just cashed in
and i know other folks yeah who are
public speakers
right they are authors and they're just
clocking in and out they don't find
meaning in that
our therapist who don't find meaning in
that right
yeah so at the end of the day you've got
to
write down these things on a piece of
paper and get them out of your head
because it feels overwhelming have you
done that
i've started but i haven't really delved
into it now
so here's where this this becomes an
adventure
because i just wrote down unable to get
pregnant
struggling to buy a house family
business
underneath each one of those becomes a
spider web
which is why did i marry her should i
stay married to her if we can't have
kids
is it my fault should i let her go so
she can go to somebody else who has kids
should we adopt like so now all this
looks should i adopt domestically or
locally or
it's 45 000 to adopt a kid in my
neighborhood right if i go private and
if i go
right so you start having those things
and write them down
and then it gets into the family
business i never even wanted to do this
so my dad was
this and i'm living his dream and that's
when these things get hard
right my dad didn't care about me you go
down these rabbit holes
and that's where you have to write it
all down all of it
all the spiderwebs entangled mess and
then you got to go through those things
and demand evidence from them almost in
a
um i don't know a
got to back out of it and say does my
dad love me yes
is my dad really passionate about this
business yes
does my dad really want me to have it
because he's built this thing and he
wants to pass it off to his son yes
do i have to take it nope
nope and that's scary because now it's
like well then go do whatever you want
to
and that's that's that's terrifying
right
um yeah so there is this weird moment
where
i think it was four years for me and my
wife maybe three and a half
that i i got a job offer in malibu
and we looked at each other and said man
we had this picture of living in texas
and having kids and living this life
let's just go move to malibu the job
came with housing let's just get out of
here
and do something totally off like total
left turn
right and so at some point you and your
wife needs to don't have that
conversation
if not this we get to paint a whole new
picture
and it's going to look different you got
to grieve the one that's not but man
there's a lot of really awesome
neighborhoods in the in the world
now meridian's pretty awesome let's be
honest be real it's beautiful
um yeah but there's a lot of cool places
young ago
you can go someplace you move to
nashville for two years and just try
something and then go back
right you can do whatever you want but
you got to go through
the part of untangling that mess in your
heart and head
my gut tells me you don't want to say it
out loud
and that's fine i'm going to keep
pressure on you but my gut tells me is
you have a picture
you've been thinking about something a
job you're interested in exploring
in a place that's not where you thought
and either with adopted kids or not
adopted kids
just you and your wife hitting the road
in a camper whatever the thing is
something tells me you've been down that
road and my challenge to
you is to step back and have that
conversation with your wife if you
haven't already
and they mean there's not a lot holding
you back how old are you
43 43 yeah
that feels like you're 100 years old but
you're not
well when it comes to kids it feels like
that for sure i know i know
you're probably not even halfway there
yeah
probably not even halfway there
have you sat down and told your dad that
you're thinking about not taking the
business
no we're uh we got a meeting set up
in the coming weeks to discuss
what that all looks like do you actually
want it you're just scared of being a
business owner
um well that's the thing i'm trying to
figure out is it just my fear of doing
this
on my own or or is it just something
that i don't want to do
what do you think i'm not letting you
off the hook that easy you can hang up
on me but i don't i
i know that you know that's the thing
man why won't you say it
uh do it say it say
it i've been i've been fearful i mean
i'm
i've always lacked confidence so that's
always been
in my been in my mind about this is it
just because i'm scared
and but at the same time i go to work
every day and i'm
just i mean i'm not happy
i know my guys feel that i'm not happy
and i'm creating a an environment that
is not a great place to work just
because of
me being happy with where i'm at
and it's not right you know how much is
that
is um resting on the heartache of not
being able to grow your family
probably a lot yeah
how's your marriage
we're uh we're good we're together in
this you know
um
you can be you can be together in
something but you can be two inches
apart on a couch but
a thousand miles away from each other
man
here's what here's what you sound like
here's what you sound like britain you
sound like a guy who's totally and
completely alone
and who's 43 and is waking up and going
whoa
whoa suddenly i found myself on an
island
i could be way wrong in that
i'm i don't feel like i'm alone i know
she's there for me and she's
she's she's on this journey with me so
good but uh
maybe we're maybe i feel like we're
alone there you go okay
excellent so here's here's the here's
the plan dude
taking over a business yeah you should
be scared man that's scary
not being able to have this picture of
his family that you had yeah that's
terrifying
it's heartbreaking
having to sit down have a hard
conversation with your dad and say hey
your life's work is something i'm not
interested in i can't even wrap my head
around that conversation
right i just well i'm 40 years old i
just want to get my wife a home
and we can't afford it yeah dude that's
that's a beating
so i want you and your wife to sit down
and
for maybe the first time in a while not
think of the things
that you're lacking that you're missing
that you're
not able to come through on but instead
i want you to say
all right let's take all the blinders
off let's say dad didn't have a business
let's say we
the country was open to us
let's say we we're just gonna call it we
know that we're never gonna have kids
it's just you and me
now what what kind of crazy adventure
could we build
and i want y'all to lean into that and
you may not fully get there because it's
gonna start with tiny houses and
campers and what i don't know whatever
people from idaho do
but it may be you know we don't have to
live here
i've always wanted to live by your
parents or i could run a construction
company in kansas
and for the same price we could buy a
home in meridian i could buy half of a
block in kansas right
whatever that looks like and you begin
to loosen these chains that have wrapped
themselves around you
as you felt yourself losing out on one
thing after another after another after
another
and 43 feels like you're 100 you're not
you're not even halfway there brother
you're not
you man
you deserve somebody who will ride or
die with you
and then you deserve to dream big and go
get it
more practically speaking you need to
have a hard conversation with your dad
sooner rather than later
and ask him to be vulnerable with you
need to sit down with your wife and plan
on okay we've gotta at some point say if
this isn't in the cards for us what's
this gonna look like
right if we can't afford a house in this
community and
we wanna buy a house and then at some
point the house has to be more important
the community got to go look somewhere
else
that's just the that's the math of it
right
or we're just going to rent until we're
70 because we're so enamored by this
neighborhood
i'd recommend moving i'd recommend
trying to find something different go
have an adventure if it tanks you can
come back in two years
maybe the housing market will correct
itself in two years whatever that looks
like
but get all the stuff out of your head
all of the derivatives drama
all the tangles and then start clicking
through one at a time
is this true is this true is this true
and then what what of this can i control
i gotta let the rest of it go
and usually what i can control starts
with conversations
hard ones with people i love thank you
so so much for that call brandon your
stud dude
now it's time to go do the hard hard
stuff thanks for calling brother
all right let's take one more call let's
go to sarah in grand junction colorado
sarah what's going on how are you
i'm really nervous i get nervous and
regular phone calls
so my heart is jumping out of my chest
right now
lucky for you this is not a regular
phone call this is just some
knucklehead on a podcast or on the
youtube so
it's good easy for everybody so what's
up um so the gist of my question
is i'm i wanted to get some objective
advice
whether it's time to just move on or if
i write that letter
and uh reach out to my family again okay
walk you through so uh details
is uh when i was three years old my
father killed my mother and my eldest
sister wow
and so we went yeah so me and my
siblings went to live with my
aunt uncle and their children how many
kids how many kids do they have
they had four were you in the home when
your mom was
murdered i i was okay
and uh you know i i have vague memories
of that day but
uh you know i was three years old so it
was you know that
it's just very vague um but anyway so
um there was always like a difference
between us like
you know that their children called them
mom and dad but we called them by their
first names and it's kind of just
there was always kind of this hierarchy
and class difference
in the home of course yeah man and uh
yeah and so i was the youngest by
six years so i everybody had moved out
and i was alone with them for quite some
time
and so i'm going through you know the
teenager phase and uh
i can't even remember what happened but
said something that my cousin didn't
like and
they he told me that i was going to end
up in prison just like my father
and obviously that made me extremely
upset to be compared to like somebody
that
murdered my my mother and my sister yeah
and uh
i so my uncle pulled me aside
and we went on a little hike to clear
our head and
he admitted to me that he looked me but
not like one of his
own children and i just feel like i
never really got past those words
and i didn't know what to do at this
point
i and how old are you now sir i'm 29
and so that was like part of the problem
is that it's been so long
and i thought i was long gone over this
you know like i'd done the work
i'd gotten past it started a new life
made new friends made a new
you know my my family with my friends
and
i don't know why it's bothering me again
it makes me feel
i don't know childish and that brings me
i don't know shameful feelings and it
just makes me feel
stupid and weak that this is bothering
me again
so do do you have any idea as to what
set this
this what brought these memories back
are you are you dating somebody and
my father was released from prison this
last september
and i think that did i don't know kind
of bother me but
i am getting uh married next month okay
and it's just like you know
he's got all his side of the family and
i got uh you know my siblings are going
to be there
but you know my brother's going to have
to walk me down the aisle there's just
you know there's differences yeah
so you may have
quote unquote gotten over this um
your body has not your body's been
carrying this for a long time
and it's all stuff that three-year-olds
should never ever see
and it experienced things that three and
four and five and six and 18
year olds should never ever experience
no child ever should be told by a family
member
you know i like you but i don't love you
as much as them
you should have never heard those words
and i'm sorry that somebody said that to
you
yeah i think it's just it's made me feel
like this feeling of like an unwanted
puppy is just like kind of like been in
the back of my mind all my life
that's exactly right how have you over
the last
you know 20 years how have you
filled that that hole
uh you know i moved kind of just ran
made new friends made new relationships
and
you know we definitely some
some alcohol and stuff like that but i
have a better grasp on that stuff now
now it really is just
you know every once in a blue moon i
don't have a problem but there was
definitely moments
in years where where i did yeah
so here's the hard truth and then i'll
give you some light at the end of the
tunnel okay
your dad murdering your mom will never
make sense
there will never be a moment when you go
uh okay
not being welcomed by your aunt and your
uncle
will never make sense
nothing anybody can say unless your
uncle was to call you
and tell you i was so wrong and i'm
sorry you were a beautiful baby i'm so
glad i got to be your dad
um
like that will never make sense you'll
never go
okay you can wrap your head around it
that your uncle was ashamed
and heartbroken and went from his own
four kids or three kids to suddenly a
seven kid
it doesn't matter you were six
right and so the heartbreaking part of
all this
is healing will not come from answers
and clarity
you have that you have all the answers
your dad did an unspeakable evil act
your uncle committed an unspeakable evil
act
right yeah and it just uh
you know it's like hold on hold on hold
on hold on hold on hold on hold on
sorry you are so good at
man you are good at whoa oh here it
comes and you can take a hard right turn
and get out of a painful situation quick
right
yeah yeah you gotta just sit in this for
a second
healing won't come from answers and
clarity it will only come from moving
forward
and so if you think of your life as a
as a story
that there's you've got some ugly hard
sentences in your story
dad killed mom period
uncle told me i was less than period
cousins made fun of me period
i let some guy take um try to fill a gap
i let alcohol fill gap i made bad
decisions whatever
period and what we all want to do
and you've got you've got trauma i can
never imagine
that 99.9 of the listeners of this could
never wrap their head around
but what we all do with trauma is we
have that pin in our hand and what we
want to do is go back and try to edit
those sentences over and over and over
and you can't
they've got peers at the end of them
what you can do the only thing you can
do
is write something different right
and so yeah
at some point you got to let that you
got to write that three-year-old girl
letter
and let her know she never should have
seen that and it was wrong
and you got to let that little
six-year-old girl know that she's
beautiful
and fun and got dealt a really crappy
set of cards
and then she got some help from somebody
and they didn't play well
and then man as you step into these new
life adventures this will happen as you
get married
it happens dad's coming out of jail your
body sounds the alarms again
and what healing is going to look like
for you is recognizing
oh that's what that is my body's trying
to keep me safe again
my body's trying to keep me safe because
there's a murderer on the loose now
my body's trying to keep me safe from
people who've hurt me in the past you
know it hurts me the worst family
the one thing that keeps us well has
been
a nuclear bomb in your heart and mind
and so you're in you're leaning back
into the one thing that was so was
torture to you
and your brain and heart are trying to
say hey we remember this script and it
didn't go well
and that's when you have to remind your
body and your heart and your mind i hold
the pen
and i get to write what comes next tell
me about this person you're marrying
he's great we we are very much on the
same level
we we have a lot of silly fun together
and it is
it's been very fun hold on is he safe
he is you trust him i do
and do you recognize you're entering
into a covenant
that the first woman that you ever knew
that covenant right
ended up tragic okay
so every time those alarms go off for
you
just drop your shoulders and say thank
you for trying to keep me safe i've got
it from here
right when you have a kid your first
beautiful little baby those alarms are
gonna set off again
and that's you know i got it i got it
thank you
we're safe because my brother's awesome
and my other brother's awesome
and my sister who i don't have any
brothers that you got they're awesome
they've been there right or died they're
gonna walk you down the aisle
is that the way you drew it up nope
is that the reality of the world you
live in yep
so we're not going to try to edit the
past we're going to write the story of
the future
and i do think at some point you're
going to have to write those kids a
letter
and let them off the hook because
they're still fighting for you hard hard
heart
right yeah
you know so what do you say i i honestly
i don't even know if my uncle
realized what he said hurt me you know
or if he was just
uh that was just the way that his brain
worked so
i i just i never knew if i should share
with him
what that actually did to me or if i
should just let it
let it go i think you should put that
brick down
i i don't know what letting him know
would accomplish
me either i don't know what he's going
to be able to tell you
that will make you go okay good
you know what i mean yeah
and so as a part of your healing if you
want to talk to him and you have that
type of relationship with him now go for
it
a punitive grenade throw won't help you
it just causes more bodies right yeah
and forgiveness is often one-sided
your decision to say i forgive you was
was your uncle your dad's brother or
your mom's brother
my dad okay
so your dad was your uncle was dealing
with so much garbage
did not have the tools did not expect to
have what happened
and then man just let you down
and at the same time hey let's be fair
at the same time give you a roof and a
house and food right i mean
did the things to keep you where you
needed to be right
and so um as i heard once i lo you got
to blame fairly
right he got you from point a to point b
man a lot of scars along the way
and i can only imagine he was dealing
with his own trauma all that to say is
your story moving forward is not about
him and
as i'm sitting here trying to unravel it
for you it does it's of no value
right now if you need him to say the
words i love you
go ask him but be ready if he says no
right
yeah i don't think it it's worth it at
this point i just uh
i wasn't sure if i was taking the easy
route or not i couldn't tell if i just
wanted to
let it go and uh sarah there's just
there is nothing out
there is no easy road here
there's not every road is a hard road in
this situation
and who's judging if you find an easy
road take it
right there's there is no
you've been through enough you've been
through enough
and so what i want you to do as best you
can is begin to
look forward not backwards and that's
hard because what you experienced was
evil and hard and and just
disaster but you got some other
knucklehead boy ahead of you saying hey
you're the one i wanna hitch my wagon to
and i love you
and he trusts you enough to be silly
with you
and he said you're you're you're my
you're my gal
and you said all right i'm in right
yep and the way you can make meaning
moving forward
is that you weren't welcomed everyone in
sarah's life is going to know that
they're welcome
nobody will out hospitality sarah
and when your little kids are born no
kid on earth will have
ever understood love like your kids are
going to understand it
right exactly that was very therapeutic
john i was nervous but
thank you so much for your help well
thank you for calling and trusting
me with this story and i want you to
know your story is going to benefit and
um be a gift to
anyone listening to this and very again
very few of us are going to experience
what you experienced but we all are
wrestling with
how do we go back and deal with old
trauma and then how do we move forward
and it's almost always both and
right it's almost always both in i'm
sorry that you went through that
but you have shown resolve and strength
and
bravery and
compassion for yourself for this new
person
man you're a really special person and
i'm glad that the world gets to hear
your story
and more importantly
when you begin to find value in you and
say you know what three-year-old you
should never have seen that i'm sorry
you know what six-year-old
seven-year-old i'm sorry you know what
dad i'm not carrying your trauma anymore
that was on you hey uncle aunt
there wasn't something wrong with me
there was something wrong with y'all
and y'all are experiencing your own
drama so thank you for the bed thank you
for the food
and i'm gonna go make my new life now
hey and brother thank you for stepping
in thank you for being the dad i didn't
have
thank you for being willing to walk me
down the aisle it's not the picture i
drew up but it's the picture i got
and now i'm going to go make meaning of
this
and you're playing a long long game
sarah a lot of us who experience dramas
kids are playing long games
because we're going to heal for
ourselves but we're going to heal for
ourselves so that
our kids have an entirely different
different system those bricks in our
backpack
we take them out and they pave a brick
path that's what legacy is right that
paves a road
that our kids can walk on that we can
walk on that our neighbors can walk on
that kids in our community can walk on
that we're never going to meet
because we did the hard work of getting
those bricks out of our backpack saying
i'm not carrying that crap anymore
you're brave and you're awesome sarah
thank you so much for the call
all right so as we wrap up today you
know what i don't want to do song lyrics
of the day let's just call it's been a
heavy show
i want everybody to know i love you and
i'm grateful that you all are walking
with us
go find your favorite song today and
listen to it um
man call somebody that you love and let
them know thank you so much and uh rock
onto the break of dawn
stay in school and don't do drugs this
has been the dr john daloni show